the day of the crash is seared in Polish
history one of those occasions when
every poll remembers where they were the
Polish Air Force plane came down in
Smolensk in Russia it claimed not only
the lives of all 96 passengers and crew
on board but a country's political and
military elite amongst the dead the
Polish President Lech Kaczynski
and his wife Maria eight years on new
questions are being asked about what
caused the tu-154 aircraft to come down
in his first television interview a
British Air Accident investigator has
told Sky News he believes the original
Polish and Russian findings of pilot
error are wrong I think they did not do
a thorough investigation they probably
it seems to be that they had come to
that conclusion very very early on and
then possibly sought evidence to
justified Russia released this audio
which it says capture the last few
moments of the flight Russian
investigators say in dreadful weather
conditions the pilot flying too low hit
a birch tree searing the wing roof Frank
Taylor was involved in the Lockerbie and
Manchester air crash investigations
he's now examined high-resolution
photographs taken by the Russians of the
Smolensk crash if the tip had been cut
off by a birch tree that the damage
would wouldn't have looked like this
well it would have been it would have
been bent back consistently backwards
rather than up down and maybe even
forward Frank Taylor says he believes
damage to the left side cabin door is
consistent with what he calls massive in
tonal pressure leading him to this
conclusion there is no doubt that there
were explosions onboard before the
aircraft hit hit the ground relatives
have long complained that Russia failed
to protect the crash site pointing to
unverifiable video such as this Russia
has refused to return any wreckage or
the full flight data recordings
political activist Ana valentinovich was
on the plane in Poland her son says he
was threatened with jail for speaking
out after the wrong body was returned to
him and that no relative can be sure
they have actually buried their loved
ones those on board were on their way to
the 70th commemoration of the Katyn
Massacre of 22,000 polish intellectuals
politicians and military officers by the
Soviets in World War two a member of the
Federation of khatyn families spoke to
us on behalf of the smelling skeletons
but wanted to remain anonymous over
fears for his personal safety this is no
longer a Polish problem this has become
a European problem and perhaps an
international problem there now needs to
be a cohesive effort to deal with both
the air accident investigation side and
the human rights violations have clearly
occurred there are some important
questions to ask Russia most of the
relatives are utterly traumatized
they've been waiting for eight years to
discover the truth what level of
intimidation have they experienced over
their quest to find the truth some
relatives have reported being threatened
and abused by hooligans I think it would
be fair to describe it as they have
lived in a climate of fear Russia says
the crash has already been fully
investigated friends and relatives of
those who died say an EU resolution
calling for an independent inquiry has
been ignored even so they won't give up
on their belief that the full story of
the Polish Air Force flight is still to
be revealed Lisa Holland Sky News